what's up guys it's your girl jess and
we're back with another video today we
are going to be
reacting to larry elder on the reuben
report don't forget to subscribe
like and comment some other videos we
should react to not gonna lie pearl a
little nervous about this one you're i'm
nervous
the last one wrecked me i'm
i don't know
no we'll just see we'll see how it goes
um look at it
they you guys requested it you guys
asked for this video i give the people
what they want okay
also also guys we are trying to get your
girl to a thousand subs so she can get
monetized too
so go her link to her youtube channel's
in the description
more videos will be coming soon i
promise she's gonna do like behind the
scenes here and fun stuff
vlogs some fun things so just be on the
lookout all right okay you ready no no
i asked you to name the most important
uh example of racism and you gave white
cops going after black people and i and
i told you gave you the facts for that
so that's nonsense so you must have
something else what else is it if you
think racism remains a problem in
america
i guess this week is a lawyer a writer
and host of the aptly named larry elder
radio show larry how's it going well
great dave thank you for having me i
appreciate it yeah thanks for coming in
i've been trying to make this happen
with you for a while oh dodge darting
you forever
caught up with me i i got you i got you
you've been in this studio before right
i have i've guessed hosted for larry a
couple times larry king that is harry
king that's that's a larry man yeah he
has a thing in his country the full hour
yeah he could
he can only have people with the name
larry that's right i guess those were so
that worked out for you uh so there's a
lot of stuff i want to talk about and in
in the beginning of the show i set up
that i am a liberal you're a
conservative my condolences
maybe by the time this show is over we
can move you to the center a little bit
and maybe by the time the show's over
weekend that's not gonna that's not
gonna happen
but that's what it's all about that's
why i've wanted to have you on the show
because i find there are some people in
the public space that i disagree with
but that i'd like to sit down and talk
about some of the ideas and i consider
you in that in that space
but before we get to the politics
i like the audience to know a little bit
about the history of the people i'm
talking about so can you just i know you
were born in l.a right give me a little
larry elder history today born and
raised in l.a my dad was a janitor he
cleaned toilets uh my dad was born in
athens georgia
doesn't know who his mother is doesn't
know what his father is rather
my name elder was the name of some dude
who was in his life the longest
my father was kicked out of his house he
was 13 years old by his irresponsible
grandmother and was on his own from that
point on
my mom grew
just though
i'm not laughing at his father's
situation
just though he said my irresponsible
grandmother
that's a
that's this is intense
oh this reminds me of what you said last
time about like wanting to tell their
whole lifestyle yeah
yeah you got to get every detail in
there me i'd been like yeah i was born
here was raised here boom bam boom i
don't give a lot of details but there's
people who
love the details
oh
grew up on a farm kind of aristocracy
for for a black woman she
owned the farm they owned the farm
anyway my dad and my mom got together
and moved to california in the 40s
i have two brothers i am as you
mentioned the lawyer
born and raised in l.a and went to
college in the east coast law school in
the midwest stayed in ohio for about 17
years came back to l.a by
smasher pass
girl
both of them
okay just wonder
what about you
pass
maybe maybe if he was like our age
but yeah pass
i just like to keep it consistent you
know
me two years ago got into tv and radio
and i've been doing it ever since there
you go all right so now we got we got
the meat of what you do
now you're not a practicing lawyer right
negative no yeah i did it for two and a
half three years and that was it i find
a lot of people uh in the public space
either were lawyers at one time right or
i know there's a ton of comedians that
were lawyers what is it about lawyers a
lot of them want to get out what's that
about i'm not sure that's true it's just
a real flexible thing to do you learn
how to reason you learn about the law
you learn about the constitution
if you're a trial lawyer you learn how
to think on your feet and it lends
itself to doing other things but
speaking about the constitution
question for you
do you think that they should
for like where we are now
look at revising the constitution
no no no because it's like um
i think if it's not broke don't fix it
okay what unless is there something in
particular you're thinking of um no
nothing nothing like off the top of my
head but i've like
a lot a long time ago i thought about i
wonder if they ever thought about like
revising the constitution
i just i think the
the constitution protects us from the
government
and that's how you have to look at it
like okay like the right to bear arms is
the big one do you know why they have
that in the constitution
so imagine in germany okay when when the
government started to override the
people right if everyone was armed
it would be a lot tougher
that's what it's for it's to protect us
from the government
so like with that example it's if the
government starts having too much power
like it's it's the right to bear arms is
about protection
okay
um yeah but this isn't about that yeah
just a question
most people i know who went to law
school at least the ones i went to law
school with uh stayed in the law yeah so
was that a perfect segue to get you to
be someone that talks for a living right
like instead of having to litigate it in
a courtroom you could litigate it on air
and bounce back and forth with people
and that's right although most lawyers
are not trial lawyers it's kind of the
image of most lawyers is that they're
glib and fast most lawyers sit behind a
desk and fill out papers they're they're
tax lawyers or or constitutional lawyers
or contract lawyers or something like
that only about 10 percent of lawyers
end up going to becoming litigators and
even a smaller number of those actually
try cases yeah all right so now let's
talk about conservatism let's do it so
i've mostly been calling out the left on
my show because i consider myself part
of the left right and i've seen the left
sort of really go off the deep end to
the left and i haven't been happy about
it so i haven't talked that much about
the right i've had a couple people on
the right so first off
uh how would you define conservatism
what do you think that even means at
this point in america in 2016 what is a
conservative well i don't mind being
called a conservative conservative i
don't consider it to be a four-letter
word but i really call myself a
libertarian
i believe in article 1 section 8 of the
constitution which gives the federal
government a small number of things to
do dave
meant money
put together an army
deal with the borders a handful of other
things that's it
welfare health care abortion same-sex
marriage doctor-assisted suicide all the
social issues that the supreme court
takes up in my view they shouldn't take
up in the first place that should be
done on a state by state basis that's
what i think most conservatives believe
as well
so i'm with
that's interesting that he said the
stuff that he listed off that it should
be on a state-to-state basis
i feel like even though
it's not i feel like it is because there
are some things in
other states that um that do things
differently from my knowledge
so that's very
very interesting yeah well i mean
because i mean some stuff
it goes both ways like there's some
conservative values yeah yeah
um so like for example
like one of them was abortion like you
have texas and you have california
yeah two
totally different yeah
and
i i didn't know that it i didn't know
that it
was like specifically
um based on like whether you're
conservative or liberal or whatever it
is that
the example that he gave i didn't know
that so well it's it's just more like
like liberals prefer more
in general guys i know in general prefer
more like federal laws so a law that
would you'd pass a law with a nationwide
ban on abortion
and conservatives would maybe think of
it more each state should decide for
themselves based on the values of like
the people oh okay
okay yeah
that that makes sense do you want a lot
of and i definitely have some
libertarian beliefs myself i think most
people are libertarian they just don't
know it the founding fathers were
libertarians the founding fathers
drafted a document that said
our rights come from
a power other than individuals
and government doesn't give us our
rights we give government our rights and
power and everything else should be left
to the states and the individuals that's
how the constitution was started that's
how the country was started and i think
that's how most americans really feel
when they really think about it
i want to get this right so i want to
look at my notes for this according to
this
you are black
is that correct that is correct that is
correct
i know he's like a little jokey joke but
why job request this clip
he said oh first question i'm gonna get
him with this one you are
like huh
oh
it was just cringe it's just like like
i'm not even gonna lie i'm a
conservative but sometimes conservative
media can be so cringe
and corny i'm just like why are you
i don't know i'm gonna say this pearl
your people
are interesting sometimes
i'm sorry they said
you're black like when you when you
wrote that down sir when you that was
your first thing i want to know what
your thoughts were like ah this is this
is gonna be viral this is gonna be good
like hmm
not african-american that's not a term i
like you how come you don't like the
term ridiculous i was born and raised in
america i've never been to africa oh
that's why he did it i forgot okay okay
okay larry elder hates being called
african-american okay
that's why that was i'm not saying it
was a good question okay
like i think that's i was thinking why
would he do it like that i feel like
he's not that dumb yeah but i mean you
wouldn't
um you wouldn't a half blind person
could yeah yeah but he has a whole
you'll see you'll see but
it's interesting that he says that
because i've i haven't heard
um someone else say that besides my mom
she's like she says like oh i don't like
being called african-american she said
i've never been to africa i don't i
don't know
like i'm not african i'm american and
i'm like it's interesting but i'm like
but you're still
black and there's still something she's
like no i'm american i'm black
but it
on the flip side for me
it's like
i understand what she's saying but it's
also frustrating because
everywhere else besides america they
for their ethnicities they say where
they're from but america we say oh white
black brown
whatever it is this is like well why why
are we the only place that says like oh
colors instead of like where your
bloodline is actually from
no it's interesting cause we were
talking about the other day like in
europe i get asked so much more about my
heritage because guys we live in london
so they might not know
but we like even now they'll be like oh
so what are you german lithuanian yeah
irish um
way more than in america because in
america you're just white yeah
and it
it's frustrating and i've had someone
ask me like well how does it feel like
when people ask you that question
it it sucks in a sense i'm like i want
to be able to say like oh i'm i'm from
here i'm from there because it's so cool
to be able to like know
where your family's from but when people
ask me i just go
i'm just i'm just black not just black
but it's like
i'm black i don't know where my
bloodline is i can't specifically say
oh
africa because i i don't know yes i'm
black i
don't know have you ever looked at doing
the dna test i have but i'm like trying
to decide on which one if y'all if y'all
know
which one to do because i've heard some
of them like use your information for
other stuff i'm like don't be spreading
my dna everywhere thank you but if you
if you know a good one let us know in
the comments down below please because i
want to know
correct that is correct that is correct
not african-american that's not a term i
like you how come you don't like the
term ridiculous i was born and raised in
america i've never been to africa
why am i an african-american most of my
people have been here longer than most
of other other the other people in this
room uh yet most people don't have a
hyphen uh you know i'm an
italian-american greek-american oh my
god that's so interesting
i don't even think about it like that
because
like i have a grandparent from lithuania
or great grandparent from lithuania and
another one from germany
huh
yeah so like if
if
i have a friend who born and raised in
africa and they moved to the states
i don't know if they're i don't think
they're a citizen right now but if they
were to become a citizen they would
technically be
african-american because they are they
were from straight from africa and that
is their main residence and then they
have another dual citizenship in america
which is african-american if we're going
like based off like the actual
like
term the term of it romanian-american
it's an absurd term it's a term that
jesse jackson almost single-handedly
crammed down the throats of our media
and after jackson began to talk about
why blacks should
have some connection to africa all of a
sudden new york times la times all of
the media began using that expression
it's ridiculous yeah i mean i personally
don't use the term african-american that
much because one time i had a guest on
the show and i referred to her as
african-american she said well i'm
actually jamaican
so you know what i mean so i guess that
that goes yeah
and i remember reading one time dave
somebody uh uh was given a description
of some suspect uh who had uh done some
crime was running away uh and uh he was
described as an african-american how do
you know where he was from it could have
been from africa could be from jamaica
could be from canada so what do you make
what do you make of that when someone
like because i know you really rail
against jesse jackson and and these guys
on the left that use and i want to talk
a lot about identity politics okay so
the guys that use these phrases what
what are they going for there
well they're what's their goal the goal
is to
tell black people that we're victims
that discrimination and racism remain
major problems in america when in fact
they don't uh and uh
oh
pearl this video
i'm not saying anything i'm not saying
anything
it's i'm i'm like interested to see like
what he says and like how he says it
because
in the black community if you
if you don't agree with the majority
they
they call you all kinds of things that i
cannot say on camera um
but
they
they like dismiss you in a sense
and
particularly i don't like it it's like
if another black person has a different
view what's the what's the difference
between us having a different view and
someone that looks like me having a
different view like we're not all the
same we don't all think the same
but it's like we all have to and that's
like the the feeling that the black
community not everybody but majority
and it sucks like why can't we think
differently he's been he's was born and
raised in l.a went to the east coast for
school and the midwest so he's touched
almost every sector of the states like
the big sectors of the state to be able
to see different things and experience
different things and experience
racism or not racism in his lifetime and
so why can't he talk about things that
he sees a different way and he's
been in law know the law and it's like
it sucks that
when people talk like this it's just
missed right away and like not enough
people actually sit down and like listen
be like okay never saw from that point i
still don't agree with it maybe but i
understand where you're coming from well
it's interesting you say that because he
says that all the time on his platform
that like like he that they call him
like a
i'm not gonna say
you're the animal
not
uncle oh uncle tom no but there's some
other ones yeah i'm not gonna yeah i'm
not gonna say there's a there's a few
and no but he'll say that um the worst
comments he gets are from his own
community yeah and it it sucks cause i'm
like
how
how are we going to
tell other people
to support
our own community
when even inside our own community we
can't even fully support each other when
we agree or disagree it's like
you don't think the same way as me and
you black okay
bye i don't want to listen to you but we
want other people to listen to us other
people to understand us and the things
we go through and whatever it is but we
can't even first do that in our own home
how how do you expect other people to do
that
if we're not doing it like we have to
set an example at first and
i don't think people really think of it
like that it's like no we this has been
done to us we all have to think the same
we all have to be the same and it may
not be that for everybody but from my
experience and what i've seen and what
i've just witnessed just in my life
that's that's my experience and that's
what i've seen you know what's
interesting i think there's a lot more
black conservatives than people really
know
and i know this just from like doing my
platform
i've had so many people like that that
are like acquaintances be like liking my
stuff and like commenting you know what
i mean like my conservative stuff like
um it's interesting because i think it's
i think there's more like
like conservative about like black
people with conservative values that you
would think you know what i mean
i would agree with that
but because
of the way
the community is set up they may not
come out and speak about it as much
because of the backlash they would get
from it so no i've had people send me
dms where they're like i could never say
this in public but like i love what
you're doing
yeah and it's just like
it sucks because it's like
we
we want to
be able to be our 100
authentic self to everybody else in the
world but we get backlash from it but we
also get backlash from our own community
and it's like
why
why is that and i could never for the
life of me understand
why
they want black people to vote for the
democratic party the democratic party
gets 95 percent of the black vote
and the reason they get it is because
blacks are convinced that the number one
issue facing the country right now is
social justice racist white cops
discrimination systemic racism
microaggression whatever new word they
come up with and it's a bunch of
nonsense the number one problem
domestically facing this country is a
breakdown of the family and uh president
obama said it i didn't a a a black kid
or a kid not just a black kid a kid
raised without a dad
is five times more likely to be poor and
commit crimes nine times more likely to
drop out of school and 20 times more
likely to end up in jail so you're far
more likely to end up in jail without
having a dad than you are because of a
white racist cop right
i wonder what the
statistics are for people who
may have had
a dad but wasn't like
present he was just there just like
provided went to work came home and
didn't like interact with them or like
try to build a relationship with them i
wonder what the stats are that if
they're like similar or
it really doesn't matter
i have no idea
might have worked a lot
yeah that turned out okay
i'd be chilling
[Laughter]
so but you wouldn't not acknowledge that
there are some systemic issues give me
an example tell me what you think the
most systemic racist issue is what is it
well i would say that because black
people in most cases in many cases were
descendants of slaves that racism as a
as an institution that it just in 2000 a
certain amount of it just exists in 2015
give me the most blatant racist example
you can come up with right now um
i think you could probably find evidence
that
in general
cops are that cops are more willing
to
shoot if the uh perpetrator is black
what's your data ben white what's your
basis for saying that last year well
look i know a lot of people would say
look what's going on in chicago i know
what they would say i'm talking about
what the facts are 965 people were shot
by cops last last year and killed four
percent of them were white cops shooting
unarmed blacks in in chicago in 2011 21
people were shot and killed by cops in
2015 there were seven uh in chicago
which is a third black a third white and
third hispanic 70 of the homicides are
black on black about 40 per month almost
500 in the
per year last year in chicago and 75 of
them are unsolved where is the black
lives matter on that the idea that a
racist white cop uh shooting unarmed
black people is apparel to black people
is bs
pearl you're setting me up
i'm sorry oh this is the setup now i'm
playing um
again my mom has had this conversation
with me and i'm like
that's not what we're talking about
right now we need to defend that
and
it's it's hard
because
it's like i want to
it's like all right
we see it
we see it a lot
but also
we see
what social media like pushes and
everything and they don't
they really don't push
any other incidents when it comes to
cop related stuff the
from what i've seen on social media they
push a lot of
um
cops doing things to blast suspects
whatever it is and
i'm not saying that it doesn't happen
it's just
i wonder if all of
the
the information is being
um
is being like put in the system
and if like those stats are 100 i'm not
saying that they're incorrect i'm just
like i wonder i wonder if they're all
being put in there
and
it's ah you okay you're gonna i'm gonna
tell you something and once you see this
you can't unsee it no there's been so
many things pearl that you that i've
seen that i'm not so remember the media
is going to push things to control
people okay because a lot of people that
are like running and stuff are like
behind some of the big media companies
like they have money invested or
whatever
watch whenever black lives matter is the
loudest
who think who's getting elected
when did when black lives matter like in
now right have you heard anything the
last couple months
i've heard that homegirl bought a
million-dollar house who the the creator
of black lives matter okay okay but i
mean like anything in the anything in
the media that happened with cops no
one's what's the last one you remember
i think george floyd was the last one
when was it
what was that what was yeah
what was happening the election
pearl now what was the other really big
one
was it the one in the wendy's parking
lot
um i was thinking of tiana
i was thinking of ferguson okay
that was like the other huge one where
it was like and what was going on
an election
and so it's like
put and i'm not
i don't think i know enough to like say
like oh there's no race like i would
never say that right
but i just think it's weird how this
stuff is always quiet after the election
yeah very loud right before i've i've
noticed that i've noticed that around
election times i'm like there's
always there's always something that
happens around election time you can
never like
not there's never something not
happening around election time
and you know what else is weird where
they raised so much money
where did it go
oh it went to her house yeah what has
black lives matter done
bought her a
million dollar house and that's
something i saw on the internet so i'm
not just saying it like like imagine how
much money they rate like like um george
floyd was huge that was national
headlines
they they have i don't know how much
money they raised but it had to be
ridiculous amounts that could find
schools that could fund a lot of things
that could really
they had people some heavy hitters
behind them
and what and what laws did they did they
pass you know what's crazy do you know
who actually did pass a law
to to get rid of like the chokeholds
trump
he i don't remember exactly what the law
was
but he's he's
like i don't even know what like what
exactly
like what's on their agenda like what
are they like what tangible results do
they want yeah
i have a friend um
that
didn't support black lives matter in the
back of my head i'm like well why not
and i have it's
my friend's back at home i have
a friend group
that um
that typically like kind of thinks the
same but we have like deep conversations
but i have
a friend that me and her we go back and
forth and we talk about stuff like this
because
she
she thinks more like you she um she
voted for trump and everything and i'm
like wow like why but we were able to
sit down and talk about it and
she talked about how she didn't support
black lives matters because she looked
into it and like what they actually
supported and the things behind them she
was like yeah no i don't support them
like
i don't care if it says black lives
matter like yes it does
black lives do matters but not the
things you support within that
interest i just i don't see them as an
effective
organization like i don't know what
they're like i i understand like the
sentiment right and i'm with them with
that
but like
what what policies are you trying to
change yeah like from what you did what
impact what changed from
this like where people just acknowledge
that black lives matter or people or
were like black lives changed from it
because the other thing is like there's
always going to be racist people like
there's oh like you can't you can't get
rid of so saying to racist people stop
being racist isn't gonna do anything if
that if it was that easy then there
wouldn't be no racism right
and so it's like what you can't really
do anything with that but like what what
laws can we put in place to help the
situation yeah and i don't like i i
don't i couldn't even tell you and i
should be able to if it's national
headlines yeah
wow
oh goodness we're only we're not even 10
minutes into this video
just let's just play the video here we
go it's complete and total bs and and
the reason for
these so-called activists saying this is
the assumption that racism remains a
major problem in america the media cnn
especially msnbc runs down whenever a
black cop shoots somebody
and it and it's some some march on
washington it's ridiculous uh black
people half the homicides in this
country are committed by and against
black people last year there were 14 000
homicides not talking about suicides
talking about homicides
half of them were black 96 percent of
them black on black of that 7 000.
where's the black black lives matter
people on that so that there's where you
would say that this is purely because of
social justice purely because they want
ultimately for people to be angry enough
to just keep voting democrats that's
right and where's where's the evidence
of a lack of social justice when a black
suspect is killed by by a cop
believe me the media is on it people are
watching it
and uh and justice will will for the
most part occur in baltimore where
freddie gray was killed
i
i
hate that the statistic
is so high for
like crime within the black community
it's
it's frustrating and i wish it wasn't
that way
at all because i'm like why
excuse me like i said earlier why are we
from the inside
going after each other like
bump whoever
whoever this person is or that person is
whatever gang they grew up and i
i
despise
i i just don't like i like what they
were initially supposed to do
the gangs and how they're supposed to
help the community now it's just gangs
are supposed to help the i don't know
anything about so um it was a
documentary i
watched and
when they set up
from what i remember has been a minute
when they set up the games it was
initially supposed to help the community
and
teach certain things to whoever decided
to
come into the gang it wasn't supposed to
be
a battlefield and wherever you
walk on the street you gotta make sure
you're not looking this way or doing
that the second third now a days i
people may come for me and be like well
you don't know anything about it i don't
know anything about it i just see the
product of it and i don't like it
um and so
i'm not saying that's the only reason
why the statistic is high but i just
don't i don't like that that is a
statistic because there's
if you if we could eliminate everything
that's all the junk that is happening
within
like the black community to where that
statistic is so high
i feel like a lot of things would change
but it's like we have to look inward
first
and
what he was talking about with the
cops and the um
the cops killing the
black people
i think the argument comes
when
they're
when the situation
is what it is and they're unarmed for me
whenever i hear that or hear any
situation i'm like why
why isn't there more
training for cops so i know there's not
a lot of training for cops i'm not
saying they're like incompetent but why
isn't there
more training to where
if
you're in
if you feel like you're in danger to
choose somebody to injure them instead
of shooting somebody to
kill them innocence i know that when
you're in a situation you may not be
thinking about that but that is your
job to do that
and so
when i hear people say there's a
is different oh that's that's what i
think about like
well if they're unarmed why
why is a gun in the situation
like why is that why isn't a taser
something that you pull out first
so um i'm going to give you a little bit
something that changed my perspective a
little bit on that so i used to sell
copiers okay and i sold copiers to this
company that trained police officers and
that was like they had like a virtual
reality where you had to pick whether
you're going to like shoot someone
and like they let me do it but it's so
hard because you don't know if they're
reaching for a gun
because it happens so quick like you
don't know if they're reaching for a gun
or if they're reaching for uh um
like it could it could just be a cell
phone
and so but if they can't see your hand
they don't know yeah
and that's that's like why a lot of
times they'll be like hands up hands up
and if people don't listen like it puts
it puts themselves in danger
both of them yeah and
it's i'm just telling it's harder than
you think oh i i believe in that
situation
i probably wouldn't be able to say what
i'm saying right now i'd be like
i was nervous and what about okay the i
can't remember the exact case but the
one
that was like when we were we would have
been in high school or maybe like early
high school
um where that guy was like punching the
police officer
you think in that case he should have
been shot
because dude was like because he was
trying to grab the officer's gun
i don't remember that case but i think
it was ferguson i'm pretty sure
and that's how the media painted it that
it was like this unarmed guy
but really man was trying to take his
gun
[Music]
and i mean and it was like this really
big dude with the small police officer
he was trying to take it and then he got
shot like
a million times yeah but
like
see it's
like
that happens like you can get shot with
your own gun oh yeah for sure and i
understand that it's just
there's just certain situations just
like oh it's like it's hard because it
you would think
one shot would be able to like stun
somebody but you have some people out
here that are
that
one shot and they're like they eat it
they eat it for breakfast and then
they're like one shot ain't gonna do
nothing to me and
and then you have to like send off
different rounds and i'm not justifying
it but it's just it's difficult because
as a police officer you're concerned
about your own safety and i don't know
if there should be
more things implemented in the beginning
to put them in those like
difficult situations
and to
make see how they react when
they're put in
a situation where they may not
particularly like somebody or they have
some unbiased opinion or unbiased
something about
a suspect and put those put them in the
situation to see how how would they
react and ask them like well why did you
react like that and if it's
not to
protect themselves or if it's just off
of unbiased opinion then it's like okay
how can we get it to where we are
conducting conducting things correctly
as a police officer and
um
and in a way that protects us but also
protects
whoever it is in this situation i i also
think body cam footage is a good thing
i think it protects both parties oh yes
for sure i think like i don't have a
problem with body cam yeah
nah i think that's a thing that's a good
thing
freddie ray died in a van i shouldn't
say was killed died in a van you have a
city that's uh 45
black uh city council is 100 democrat
the majority of city council is black
the top cop at the time was was black
the number two cop was black the
majority of the command staff is black
the the mayor is black uh the ag is
black uh and yet here we are talking
about racism i mean it's it's absurd
yeah absurd so it's funny i find myself
caught in between this a little bit as a
liberal where i want to always try to
defend the other so in this case the
other being black people i i'm always
sympathetic to that and that yeah yeah
at the same time i hear you laying out a
pretty solid well just the fact i'll
tell you something else too that was
just a study
university of washington
and it turns out cops were more
reluctant more hesitant to pull the
trigger against the black black suspect
than a white suspect
probably because of the fear of being
accused of racially profiling and the
fear that the civil rights establishment
was going to come down on them so if
anything uh whites are more likely to be
shot by a cop under under certain
circumstances than a than a black person
and in last 30 or 40 years the number of
percentage of suspects killed by
cops who are black has declined 75
however the percentage of whites killed
by cops has flatlined yeah and so if
anything people are more concerned about
shooting black people for fear that
they're going to be called racist and
almost all every one of these incidents
whether it's eric gardner in in new york
who died because he was selling lucy's
and resisted arrest whether it's tamir
rice in cleveland who was twirling
around the gun whether it's michael
brown and ferguson
who had just committed an ar strong
armed robbery almost every one of these
incidents involves somebody resisting
arrest why don't you just do what the
police tell you my dad said when i get
pulled over have my hand at ten o'clock
have my hand at two o'clock say yes sir
say no sir make sure my paperwork is in
order and if i feel the cop is
mistreating me get a badge number and
deal with it later on if jeff
it's oh
i i understand and hear what he's saying
it's just hard for when though there's
those situations where
people did like
not resist and they did everything and
it still resulted in yeah
the terrible ending it's like well
what do you what do you do about that
like how how can you justify that do you
think that's the norm
from your experience like with you with
police and like with your friends with
police do you do you find that to be the
exception or the rule
um
and i'm not swaying either way like it's
whatever i
i don't know because i've heard about
um incidents like that and i've had
friends who had family members that were
in positions like that and it resulted
badly
and i
i don't know if that's the norm it's
like there's a
i've heard in california it's actually
worse
would you agree i've heard in california
it's actually bad
yeah and so that's why i'm
surprised not surprised but
interested that he has the view that he
has because of
where he's from and how california is
especially la county it's
l.a county is a state in itself it has
so many people that live there and
there's just been
it's a lot in la and i can't speak on it
speak on it because i haven't lived
there for
a long amount of time to be able to
speak on it but
it's hard when
he says this and said oh all you have to
do is this isn't this
but then like
we
we do it but something still ha that
happens and then you have people like i
shouldn't have to do all that but it's
like you
if this is what you need to do to
essentially
put yourself in a better situation and
not
make make anything make the cop feel
uncomfortable then comply
but it's like
it's
because i think the other problem is
there's power hungry people yes like if
anything if anything like
i think the biggest problem with police
if you is you get those guys that are
just so excited to have any ounce of
like authorities and they just want to
like tell you what to do yes and they
just want to be a dick and an [ __ ]
for no reason like i really
honestly um
i didn't like i've always had
interactions with the cops that were
fine but i had a cousin
that
was addicted to drugs so he was he was
very much involved with police but like
he had a lot of really bad you know
experiences but at the same time he was
also a crackhead
so i'm like
you might have done something yeah it
might have been your own fault
but so but i don't so for me i haven't
really had issues but i've seen
like mostly at parties in college where
the police are just like
they're just dying to have something to
do
and be a dick for no reason and i feel
like
there's more
there's more cops like that that are
giving just
police officers a bad rep is just the
ones that
are
money hungry that have that want to be
in that sense of power and don't know
how to properly use it and that's
something that i've thought about and i
think i forgot who i was having this
conversation with
about that and it's like
if you
are a police officer
you should put away whatever bias
whatever you feel about any type of
person because
now your job is to protect
said person that you do not like and if
you are in a situation to where you
put your bias in front of what you're
supposed to do you don't need to you
need to take off that badge and step
away from it because
what about if a doctor
is supposed to be able to help
anybody and everybody in whatever they
study and you come in and they look at
you like i don't like gingers so i can't
help you and you're like about to die
it's like no you
you cannot
do that because
as a
as that job you're you're for all people
no matter what you do when you go home
no matter what you think when you go
home when you step inside that job that
is your job to do that and i feel like
there's just
there's cops that forget that and they
have their bias and their
their proudness that they want to insert
in every situation and
it gives the ones that are actually
trying to make a change a bad name and
so they just group them all together and
they say all cops are bad when i know
that there's some good cops out there
that want to make a change and want to
make a difference you know what's
interesting
so i had a guy at my school that was
like arrested by police okay
and
he
um i think he was arrested illegally or
some i don't know exactly what happened
but he was like crying about how the
police were so mean to him whatever but
i was at that party
so you're being an [ __ ] to them like
he was like super drunk he was like
all like like dude i mean so then they
turned on the camera for the five
minutes the police were like kind of
rude back but i'm like you didn't get in
the part where he was like you have like
20 18 year olds here that are smoking
doing like it's illegal you can't
so i don't know it's like i see both
sides because on one hand i i see these
power hungry cops that just wanna are
like they're just so excited to have
power but then i see these teenagers
that are being a dick to police for no
reason
yeah and so it's like i kind of i see
both you know yeah
jesse jackson and al sharpton and obama
and the whole group of them told black
people to do that we'd have a lot fewer
of these things to deal with in the
first place yeah all right so i'm i'm
with you i'm hearing a lot of what
you're saying here so as a black
conservative then who now you've you've
laid out your case there but you haven't
laid out yours i asked i asked you to
name the most important example of
racism and you gave white cops going
after black people and i and i told you
gave you the facts for that so that's
nonsense you must have something else
what else is it if you think racism
remains a problem in america give it to
well i think it remains a problem
it may not be systemic in that we have
it's not like you're not being hired
because you're black there's no systemic
reason you know legal reason that that
exists that kind of thing but i think
that racism as a general
uh i need some theory i need some i need
some specifics right you gave me the
white cop thing what else give me
another example what do you think is a
problem
well well
as a black conservative tell me how do
you know how do you get people to come
around you're the one who made the
assertion that racism remains a major
problem in america i asked you to give
me an example you gave me white cops
going after blacks i as far as i'm
concerned you didn't hold it up very
well what's the other argument you have
what what's the other thing well i don't
know that it's systemic in that in the
sort of macro system i'm not mad i don't
why i know this has been just a thing
that
people have said about black people why
is it
why from your perspective why do you
think when
black people may be getting passionate
about someone something or like
amped up about it and it
it comes off as them being mad or upset
oh
i just think the guy on the left is
getting roasted and he's okay do you
upset like i think he knows
because i'm telling as someone in media
i know when i'm getting a viral moment
and you know when you're losing
like i've had people on my show and they
come with like facts and i'm like oh no
like i don't
um well why do i think that i don't
think he seems mad i don't think the
other guy
i think he just thinks he's losing okay
because he because he did not take it
that way no i i don't think he's mad at
all but he said i'm not getting mad just
the fact that he
has to say that yeah that he has to say
that it's like this shouldn't be a thing
you two you two are discussing something
like you shouldn't have to say i'm not
getting mad because of what you're
passionate about what you're talking
about you're trying to help him
understand and it's coming off as
excitement but
when it comes to black people comes off
as mad and i'm like
why it's like as you get excited about
something you may have the same tone and
voice as him yeah but if
if we were excited about the same thing
and you were expressing it i was
expressing it
for me it may come off as like oh no i'm
like don't get mad i wasn't trying to
make you upset it's like i'm not mad i'm
just like expressing it right so
i don't know
that's a good i never thought about it
like that but he like has to say that
and so i it's things like that
that he may not
it may not be
racist and he may he may think that
there's so racism is not a big thing in
the world but it's things like that that
it's like that is programmed
in us just like subconsciously
to
to like do or to say or people have that
reaction
and
like where did that all start how did it
all start yeah
i don't know
i just think that's part like that
reaction there is just part of the
debate and maybe this is just like my
bias and how i see it but like because i
find myself saying that stuff too to
people when i'm like kind of going out
there and i'm just saying like look like
it's okay
but
but i'm about to roast the [ __ ] up
because then you know you're about to
get toasted like a marshmallow
but we're cool
yeah we're cool but let me let me just
roast it a little bit like do you
remember when um the girl the basketball
girl was on and i could just see her
getting like yeah and i was like i'm
sorry
i didn't say i'm not mad but i was just
like i'm sorry yeah no offense well i
just want to let you know this like you
know the fact that i'm about to
you're about to go viral
you're about to be put on the viral
train
yeah
i was going to say something else but
i'm going to just let them talk okay
that's exactly what that's yeah believe
me that's a hundred percent so we can
have you likes are not getting into
school bs that we have a race we have
affirmative action so a black person
with a with an sat and a gpa
of x will get into a school faster and
easier than a white person with an sat
or a gpa of x and if going to going to
school is a route to the middle class
you can make an argument that blacks
have an easier route to middle to the
middle class if you're talking about
blacks about poverty
the poorer you are the more accessible
loans and grants are for you uh the the
the problem the biggest burden that
black people have in my opinion again is
the percentage of blacks 75 percent of
them that are raised without fathers
and that has every other social negative
consequences connected to it crime uh
not being uh able to compete
economically in the country being more
likely to be arrested that's the number
one problem facing the black community
and when i hear people tell me about
systemic racism or unconscious racism i
always say give me an example and almost
nobody can do it
i wonder
if anybody has ever brought up
redlining and gentrification
within the communities because i i'm not
100 sure about how gentrification works
but from what i'm seeing back home
it's
it's in a sense like
not
not helping and i know
i know they say it's to
help the community look better help the
community
in xyz what is that i think that's
that's when they move the lines for
votes right for gentrification yeah so
it may there may be other stuff but what
i know from it is they will
take these they will take low and
commune low-end communities and put
nicer housing in it so like if you were
to go to la right now or anywhere in
southern california in like the
rural areas you'll see all these nice
apartment buildings being built like
right in the smack dab of
these communities and it
essentially is taking the people that
have been there for years and moving
them out because these nice apartments
now are skyrocketing the prices of
living and it makes it hard for the
people that are living that have been
living at a steady rate and
it pushes them out to
further work from where they are
and i don't know how that's
helping the community when the community
is being pushed out
and so i don't know if anybody's ever
talked to him about that or redlining
and most of these
um
most of these
nice apartments that are being built are
in the redlining communities i just have
a question would it because in my head
wouldn't the nice neighborhood like the
nice
apartment complexes would bring richer
people with more money right
and so wouldn't that help the businesses
because like in the area because they
would have
money to spend on them and then like
then the businesses would be able to
employ more people that are low income
like because in my head that would help
but i could be wrong
it it would because the um
because obviously the rich people are
gonna be able to pay more and help the
businesses out more
but with that on the other hand
it
is raising at such a substantial rate
that no matter if
they can employ the people that already
live there it's like they don't have
like they're here and it raises to here
and they don't have that
safety net or that gap there to be able
to
get up there as quickly as it's rising
and so it's forcing them as they're like
pushing them out to where because i live
like on the outskirts of la county and
it's pushing them out towards
us and
it's like taking
it's taking the community out of the
community so people who have lived there
for years or years
they're moving out to an area where
they've maybe never lived i'm just not
sure how you'd prevent that because it
just seems like
you know if someone
wants to buy a piece of property like
they should have the legal right to yeah
so i just i'm not sure how you could
really like what you could do about it
without passing some really wild laws
that wouldn't make sense yeah that's
it sucks because because you kind of see
that in new york where they have a lot
of laws to that like prevent
oh my gosh i read this book so long ago
so but i know new york has a lot of
issues with housing because they have so
many laws that seem like they were put
in place to prevent something like that
like um they like rent ceilings okay
like where you can't raise the rent
above a certain
price but then
which sounds nice
until no then people are like why would
i
build an apartment complex
i'm not going to make any money
and then
in new york you always hear about they
can't find housing it's the same thing
in california actually yeah
it
finding housing in california is
ridiculous and
i
i couldn't tell you why and i
i wonder if someone brought this up to
him would he think
that
it's because of there was some laws put
in place or did it stem from racism
um
like what do you mean like the red the
red lining and the gentrification
because essentially the
from my knowledge and stats may say
different essentially
what gentrification does
in
these communities it brings in the rich
the rich people the rich other and then
it kicks out the people that have lived
there and typically people that live
there are
black people from from my knowledge and
it may become right
my um
lack of knowledge maybe i don't know i
think it just sounds it sounds like to
me it's about money
because i because i think of my parents
right and when they they like they've
invested in properties before
and like we this this wasn't really um
like this this was like the town i'm
from is pretty white all together so
this this had nothing to do with race
but more money but like they purchased a
big piece of land and because nothing
was really there and it was just like
poor like farmers basically and now
the suburbs you know what i'm saying
it's like moving out okay and the price
of those has gone up yeah but that's
that's kind of like because when you
look at properties a lot of times you
want like to get a cheap plot of land in
a neighborhood that's coming up yeah and
then sell it for more later yeah i can
i can see that as well because
one
there's things that are coming to la
within
the next
four years
two years i think
yeah no
2028 the olympics are coming to la and
so there's things that they have to put
in place now
that
essentially builds up la and i can see
it being
money and not being um
based off of racism because essentially
the more and more people that come to la
the more more money they bring in la is
a huge city for famous people for the
industry whatever it is that you're
getting into and now that
being a content creator is a
viable job now more and more people are
moving to la so i could be
i could just subscribe
i could see i could see
nobody thinking it be about
about race and it be about money like no
i know i'm going to get a boatload of
money if i build here in this community
and the certain things that are popping
up around the community i i could see me
making bank here so i could see it like
that
do you think that despite what you've
said about
president obama do you think that now
that he's out of office maybe he could
step into the role that you'd like to
see him in so instead of america turning
to jesse jackson and farrakhan and
sharpton
maybe they can turn to you but if not to
larry elder but if not to larry elder
that maybe obama when you disconnected
from politics can actually talk about
some of those things because i mean you
addressed it a second ago you said he
did mention the family and mention
fathers and all that so is there a
chance do you think there's a chance for
that i'm not optimistic because uh in
his last press conference he talked
about we still have a great deal to do
on race by the way when people talk
about a great deal to do on race all
they really mean is how black people
feel about white people and vice versa
they don't care about hispanics they
don't care about asians they really care
about the relationship between blacks
and whites
why why
why is that
like i
why actually yeah we never hear about
asians yeah we
it's
i watched this clip it was so long ago i
kind of forgot about it it's crazy
because
i
surprisingly i think about this stuff
sometimes and i i'll have conversations
with myself but i only know as much as i
know and so i'll be like i wonder why
and i've asked myself like i wonder why
we don't hear about
the way
or any other people besides black and
white like why is that the main two
group of humans that we talk about so
much it's like there's so there's so
many different people in america
but the main two that we talk about so
she's like
i wonder how other
other races feel like i want to be
talked about too i just remembered
something that i read in sowell's book a
while ago
and he said if he wants to test
something for like
if it's about race right if they want
because you have to like measure racism
on some level like what you do is you
find a different group with the same
like skin color
okay
and so he would put it against like
indians like indian americans because
they're dark okay or you know what i'm
saying
and it's like
because i think he was talking about
economically like he wanted to see if
like it oh my gosh i'm butchering this
please don't clip this guys
and but he said it was because
but like indian americans do better than
white americans
they're like one of the highest
performing groups like lowest on crime
highest on
an income like they make more than white
people wow
obama has throughout his eight years in
my opinion when he could have ignored
the race card or put it in perspective
picked it up uh whether it's cambridge
police or whether it's trayvon martin if
i had a son who looked like trayvon
whether it's invoking ferguson whether
it's hiring somebody like eric holder
who's lecturing the country on race and
racism
obama i think believes that racism
remains this huge massive problem in
america despite his election and despite
his re-election and i don't and so i
don't think he's going to say the right
thing and do the right thing i think he
i think he's encouraged black people to
think of themselves as victims as
opposed to saying look at me i busted my
butt
my parents uh made sure i had a good
education i didn't make bad moral
mistakes uh i got married before i had
kids follow my model and you'll be fine
he has not said that at all what he said
is we have real problems in this country
he embraced the black lives matter
movement i mentioned trayvon martin i
mentioned some of the other things in my
opinion
the reason that a lot of people voted
for obama was because they thought he
was going to do exactly what you
suggested which is to heal us put things
in perspective
tell young black people they ought not
be angry when they're pulled over by a
cop all the cop is doing is his job
instead he did the opposite so i'm not
optimistic at all that he'll play that
kind of role that you suggest yeah
that's very very
interesting that he says that he as he
was talking um something that kanye west
said
popped into my head when he said that um
slavery was a choice
um
and when he said that
i was at first i was like what do you
mean like they didn't choose at all like
everybody else then i sat there and i
was like well let me
try to understand
what he is saying i'm not saying that
they volunteered as tribute to be a
slave
but
nowadays if you think
of yourself as
a victim
that's a mindset and you're not like he
was saying that
barack obama he
we had a first black president
ever
and
it's like you can shed light on the
great things and the thing the way that
the world world just america has
progressed over year for you to be able
to be in that position but if you don't
if you don't talk about that if you talk
about the
all the hard stuff we have to go through
this is hard this is this and that like
they're gonna be there but if you switch
the narrative and shed light on the
great things and how america has changed
then you'll get out of that mindset and
out of that victim mindset of
everything everything is hard for me no
matter what it is because i'm black
everything's going to be hard no matter
how hard i try i'm never going to be
able to do this because i'm black like
no
like
yes there's going to be things that
people you can't stop what people think
you can't stop people's actions but if
you think of like no i can do this
because of this and the third i can work
hard at this be this and if i see
somebody that's not black and i can
still do it it doesn't matter if i'm
black or whatever i'ma do it because i
want to do it and
[Music]
i feel like there needs to be
there needs to be more people
talking that way towards the black
community to shed light on like
look at where we've come from look at
all the great things that black people
can do now that they could not do before
xyz
and
how much you can do if you want to go
into the medical field if you want to go
into the tech field whatever field it is
you can do it don't let the things that
have happened in the past stop you from
seeing the progress of the country and
seeing that you have you have an
opportunity doors are being opened more
and more doors are being opened for
just people in general to be able to do
stuff also black people
well and you know it's interesting i
think one of the
greatest ways to fight racism is success
you're like because then they can't say
nothing about you
if you're successful like what you gonna
call me on my name cool i got i got
money i don't care it doesn't affect me
like call me anything you want what are
you doing breaking that family dollar
okay cool
i'm over here have my own business
running a million dollar company cool
call me whatever you want do whatever
you want
yeah i would send money
i want to i actually do want it
subscribe money
money money money
so the way we've demonstrated i hope i'm
wrong yeah i i hope you're wrong too i i
don't know but is this a is this the
same interview or is this another no
it's the same interview it's all one
okay because they're
they look different no no they're the
same it might be
no it's the same it might be a different
camera angle okay the way we've
demonized cops as part of this i agree i
mean i see a lot of times people are
just screaming about how evil cops are
and they're hunting people down all this
stuff
i don't know a ton of cops but i knew
some in new york and i know a couple
here i mean
generally they're trying to do good
right i mean
do you have any experience in which have
you ever been pulled over and
i probably have been pulled over maybe
more than almost anybody you know i got
my driver's license when i was 15 and a
half my learners permit and then when i
was 16 i was able to drive by myself and
i probably looked like i was 12. so i
got pulled over probably a hundred times
and with the exception of one or two
instances uh the encounter was brief and
professional uh one time a cop told me
to take my head out of my ass
that was the first time i got pulled
over by the way my god i have a story
that i just thought of do you remember
that black lives matter guy
he did this whole rant of how this cop
pulled him over for no reason right and
this cop was like i think it was in
michigan it was somewhere in the midwest
okay
and no he had this whole brand he puts
it on social media the cop comes forward
and shows the body cam footage
man didn't do anything oh wow this dude
like just made it up
wow
and see that's on the flip side that's
another thing
is that's why the camera is good thing i
think yeah
definitely because
now
you it
there's people that try to like
go viral for because they know that
that's something i'm not saying
everybody for that situation it's like
okay
i don't know what was going through his
head but from outside looking in it's
like well why why would you lie on a cop
if the situation was
gucci and there's nothing that happened
and like you have people that be in
situations and don't lie on cops but
they
don't
they just don't get any like option to
come forth but you had a safe situation
but you want to lie and then it it's
like it puts
the real situations in a bad situation
you're like well then what if this
person was lying there they're all
why would you lie about that right there
i first of all
sir you are making
money
why aren't you rich to be caught up in
that why and it's like yo you
ruined you've ruined
any possible
anything because you wanted more money
you thought in your head
i'm going to do this
and it's going to be great it's going to
work out perfectly
no
but first why
you are a talented singer a talented
actor and your family is talented people
like
like
you could if you didn't like what you
was making on the show okay finish out
the season finish out the whole thing
and then do something else make music be
independent be on whatever else and then
up front say i want to make this much
and if they don't like it okay go on to
something else i'm like
you make
how much money on empire and you want to
do this to yourself and sir
you're dying you're done in the industry
well it's like how do you protect both
sides
that's the question yeah
i like i see both sides like actually
there's power hungry cops
and there's people that want attention
on social media and will use a real
problem that we have to get it yeah so
how do you
i i don't have the answer i have for
sure i don't have the answer i don't
it's hard because it's like if you
if you try to protect
one side
the other side is going to lose
something and vice and vice versa or if
you try to protect both there's going to
be something that
doesn't make sense to implement
for one side or the other and it's like
i
i do think
that
if you're gonna go on social media and
accuse a cop of something you should be
willing to go to court
yeah because i don't think it's fair for
you to like have a public court of
opinion and sway people's opinion
without going to court and it's the same
thing i think with assault allegations
if you're gonna publicly achieve accuse
someone of an assault allegation like
you should be ready to go to court yep
yep but
i guess jesse was in fact ready he just
you know i will give him that he was
really he's he's got it all lined up he
had the
show written
and
it was so cold out
like look at i'm sorry the the crazy
trumpies they're there okay i i agree
with you there's some crazy trump
supporters
but they they're not trying to get you
in the cold in zero degrees in chicago
i'm from chicago no ain't nobody outside
in zero degrees in chicago i've been
there in the winter even the gang even
the gangs stay inside yeah they like
goes down when it's cold it's too cold
outside who i'm shooting outside of zero
degree weather my trigger finger gonna
be frozen i can't pull nothing like no
it's gonna be like this thing like you
know what
tomorrow we'll try it again tomorrow
it's gonna be two degrees warmer so
let's try it again
not look at like
he did not think this thing
and that's dedication on his half
because he he was willing to go out and
zero degrees to fake a crime
i at least our respect i respect you
willing to die by the line
it just sucks because now like if that
situation if that situation happens to
someone they're gonna be like how do we
know they're telling the truth and
they're gonna have to go through even
more steps
to prove that this was like really
something that happened because of
someone else's stupidity yeah well and
you it makes you wonder how many times
does this happen and and
nothing no because because the way the
way i look at
when things happen to celebrities it's
like indicative of the society so like
with amber heard and johnny depp
women have been getting away with abuse
that's been happening in society now it
happened to a celebrity so it's coming
to the forefront yeah so to me it's like
that had other people had to have done
this too and probably got away with it
the same way women got away with that
yeah but the question is how do you
protect both sides
i don't know let me know in the comments
because i don't if y'all have the
answers let us know because we don't
yeah i was driving and there was a light
behind me and i knew i hadn't done
anything anything wrong so i sleep going
the guy pulled over and screamed at me
and he goes why don't you pull over and
i said what i said to you well i didn't
i didn't think i did anything wrong and
he said whenever you see some lights
behind you you pull over get your head
out of your ass and he was right i
should have had my head ahead of my ass
you know
the instances in which cops kill blacks
has declined 75 percent in the last 45
years according to the cdc while the
instances in which cops are cops kill
whites has pretty much flatlined and so
it's going down it is very very very
rare for the cops to kill anybody let
alone an unarmed black person of the 965
people that were killed by the police uh
in 2015 less than four percent were
white cops killing an unarmed black man
it is very rare by contrast 400 people
were injured by lightning last year but
only 250 people were killed black people
were killed by police so it's very very
rare so how much of this i know you talk
about fake news and i want to get to
that but how much of this is
because the media is complicit in all
this so for example just this morning i
think the oscar nominations were put out
i haven't even seen them yet but
apparently there are more minorities
this time i guess there are some more
latinos and uh dev patel and and some
more black people right and you know for
the last couple years there's been this
oscar so white thing to me
and i can only speak for myself this is
like keep your eye is just off the ball
you're just paying attention to the
wrong thing where
it's nice to have people nominated for
these things but they're irrelevant in
the scheme of what's important uh what
you should be caring about is education
and all that right but the media has
made such an importance out of this that
it's like it's getting the black
community's eye off what's actually
important which would be education and
family and some of the other i i i
couldn't agree with you more um
with the oscars thing um
i think it was i think i watched the
oscars last year
and i had noticed that there was more
um minorities that were um in
the categories nominated that's where
nominated and
i was like okay cool great and i but i
know like
a lot of them didn't win because i think
that year um
what is that one show from out here it
was like
uh
bridgerton no no it was um
oh my goodness it was like how house of
something i can't remember but they
swept it
every award was going to them going to
them going to them and i was like wow
i don't know the thing behind the oscars
i don't know
[Music]
how they vote but just to have the
opportunity
to
see more minorities at the oscars was
cool and i liked it but in the end
people were like they had all these
great nominations but nobody won the sat
in the third i think oscars is like off
of like people voting but also the sales
that they made and stuff that happens
throughout the year
and if i'm wrong someone let me know but
um
whenever i hear people say like oh
this but like there wasn't enough uh
black nominations or if they don't like
something i'm like create it
like if you don't if you don't like it
if you think that there should be more
of something
implemented somewhere create it if you
want an
all black award show
create it there's a comedian who
um
i've followed him for years and he kept
getting no's and knows from hollywood
and everything and so he created his own
his own streaming service and now he's
able to put out what he wants to put out
and employ people in the black community
the way that he wants to employ them and
it's like
if there's something
that's how i see it if there's something
you don't like
put it together create it if you want an
all black awards show
go
for it
how do you know the difference between
like
racism and people just ending up where
they're supposed to end up
i don't i don't know yeah i don't see i
don't know
because i've
there's certain instances where
it's just it is what it is and you can't
do anything about it and then there's
instance where it's like
you you get that feeling like what's was
that a little racist but
i
i don't i don't know i couldn't because
i think about that with like sexism too
where people will say like oh it's
because she's a girl or whatever but i'm
like how do you
how do you know that for sure
and it kind of goes back to like
i don't know like i don't know how you
would know i don't i don't i'm never
going to say it doesn't exist yeah but
it's just like i don't know how you
would know the difference between like
those the people nominated being just
very talented all together and it just
happened that the person that won was
white yeah or versus
like someone behind the scenes at the
oscars is racist yeah
see i don't and then like they never
when they're calling out racism they
never say who it is mm-hmm like they
just say oh it's the oscars well there's
people behind the oscars so which people
yeah which ones call out the people
oscar's is isn't just the statue yeah
who are the people actually doing it and
if you don't like it whoever the oscar
people are
get them out get more people in there
that you want i don't know how that
works but then it goes back to
in another way quotas
do you want them do you want them
picking people
based on the color of their skin like
isn't that again saying they need
special handouts yeah
yeah and
this
like will smith one i mean i know he's
in the news for the wrong yeah but no
one would ever say he got that award
because he was bl like no one would ever
say that he's so talented
yeah
on the flip side there's a
there's a
people that are i would say more
talented than will smith not knocking
that he's not talented that have never
received any type of awards
who's more talented than will smith
i would say
i would say denzel because he's you've
been in the game for a lot longer and
that's the first person that pops into
mine really because i think a will smith
has been in bigger movies than him
now i don't think so
i'm not i'm not a movie person i'm not
like i'm not yeah i am not the one to
ask about this denzel has some heavy
hitters i just think of um seven pounds
and oh my gosh what's the one
where will smith was with the kid
and
um
i don't know what what did denzel do the
pursuit of happiness i cry
i cry every time they're at the bathroom
name what will smith movie have you not
cried
if you if you see
any will smith movie
he something that me and my family point
out he
runs
in almost every one of his movie and he
cries it was like
it's it's a funny thing but that's a
little off stuff a little off subject
that's one thing that i saw when during
the war shows i was like
will
you cry that's that is you you are going
to shed a tear in your acting so it's a
part of you so i'm like are those real
tears or those acting tears
i had thought about that video wait wait
said what did denzel do that was better
than that what movie i'm not a movie
person so i don't i don't really watch
tv so
um you have a
training day as a big one have you ever
seen training day i don't think so okay
and then you have remember the titans
those are i know there's bigger ones but
those i think the pursuit of happiness
is bigger than those you don't think so
why haven't i seen them
because um
smasher pass denzel washington when he
was younger i would be like hey
he got a smash hello denzel
you know his name is pronounced denzel
and not denzel for real yeah he said
that it's pronounced denzel pencil i did
not know that
i said why is this important to you
and he said because it provides role
models it enhances the self-esteem of
black people that's what he said
i said are you aware that black boys and
black girls have higher self-esteem than
white girls and white boys this has been
tested for decades it's been the case
for a long time and there are very very
few asian actors and actresses yet
asian americans japanese americans
chinese americans and korean americans
on a per capita basis make more money
than virtually anybody else in this
country
that's another thing
that community
i feel like is
underrepresented
in a lot of
film tv
in a lot of industry-based stuff i in um
like the main things i feel like they
are underrepresented
you really don't
hear anything from them and i often
wonder like if they
if they feel a way
like that they're not being
represented in certain areas well i
think it's just like what interests are
in a community like you know our asian
people are overrepresented in academics
probably medicine i would guess
you know it's just like i think certain
communities like are more interested in
different things based on like values
like german i'm german right my brothers
are engineers germans are very often
like there's just certain cultures that
like
you know they tend to be in different
industries
so it's the question is is it is it
racism against asians or is it asians
just aren't as interested in
entertainment
um
it's like there's not a lot of asian
guys in the nba but nobody says the
words write out my yeah
and that's
and that's and i'm telling you once you
start looking at the world this way you
start to like think about it differently
because people always talk about
disparities
but what would
there's nothing that's out gonna be a
hundred percent representative of the
pop like even if we took engineers
or a random job like there's no industry
that i can think of that's gonna be a
hundred percent
represent exactly what the population is
yeah
like i got my gears turned
i'm just thinking about like different
scenarios where
one
one ethnicity is more in this area but
you don't
hear anybody saying well
we need more this in
this field or this area
like yeah and that's the other thing is
like you don't want a society where they
push we need more of a certain race in a
field like that's to me that's racist
like because i don't think it matter i
don't like on my show right people will
always comment they'll be like oh it's
like always like black people coming on
but
those are the people that want to come
those are people that want to come i
don't cast it that way i just say who
shows up
exactly and like you were on the
basketball team there's two other girls
on the volleyball team you just showed
up more than they did you're more
interested in it yeah and it's like it
didn't it wasn't
in certain things i feel like that
it shouldn't just it shouldn't be
pointed out that
oh
the obvious shouldn't be pointed out and
it's just
it's frustrating because that's how
that's how it is like oh you have more
white people here than
hispanics or
um
orientals or blacks you have more this
than it's like
you don't know what
you don't know if they're trying to get
trying to get more to be able to
represent you don't know what they're
doing behind the scenes but people see
it at face file and then they
just say racist racist racism yeah or
even even on my shows right because i
kind of understand where people in
entertainment are coming from because i
recruit for these i've only had one
asian girl on my show yeah the whole
time i've but i've had more like white
people black people than than asians i
just think they're not
in that case as interested in
entertainment they're like no i don't
want to come on your podcast yeah
yeah because if it's not something that
is deemed of importance
in the community in general
people are more hesitant to
to do it so like something like this
talking about this this isn't deemed as
popular from my knowledge in the black
community talking about stuff like this
but
you're you're going to get people that
are going to
want to talk about this like me
i mean i'm kind of forced to because i'm
getting red pill but no
but yeah
i give you the option to walk away you
know that no kitty
you know that yeah yeah i come back
because i enjoy it
so it's utterly irrelevant yeah and for
us to pay attention to this and it's
also not true if you look at the last 15
years or so roughly 10 or so of the
nominees for the major categories have
been black people they've been a couple
of years where where there's been a
shutout uh but um add it all up it's
about parity with population right so
that's the irony it actually it's within
a couple of percentage products it
actually has been a priority and and
jamie foxx who got an oscar for for ray
right uh uh said uh
great movie oh i've seen that i've seen
that great movie i'm telling you i would
have
sent up letters upon letters i would
have burnt down the oscars if he did not
get something for that movie i'm telling
you that man said okay ray i'm going to
take your soul out of your body and i'm
going to encompass you he became ray
charles and there
i would put money there is nobody else
that could have done that no and can we
talk about blind men cheat now
you can't even see in the movie
it was all about the wrist it was all if
it was super little chunky now man
i need a slim rest i think i swam you
britney i i saw it a long time ago so i
i don't remember it too well because i
watched it when i was a kid i haven't
seen in a couple years but i just
remember being a kid and being like he's
blind and he's still cheating
like how amy
i mean great movie that's not that was
not the point of the movie i just needed
to put that in this reaction
i mean if it's you ain't got to be you
ain't got to see to know what to do so i
mean
if it
works in connection with this oscar uh
for white movement he said
act better
be better
raise your game
don't demand don't yell don't scream get
better act better you gotta knock you
gotta stop
okay we gotta go back
oh okay okay
i think we're composed now
it's been the case for a long time and
there are very very few asian actors and
actresses yet uh asian americans
japanese americans chinese americans and
korean americans on a per capita basis
make more money than virtually anybody
else in this country so it's utterly
irrelevant yeah and for us to pay
attention to this and it's also not true
if you look at the last 15 years or so
roughly 10 or so of the nominees for the
major categories have been black people
they've been a couple of years where
there's been a shutout
but um add it all up it's about parity
with population right so that's the
irony it actually it's within a couple
of percentage products it actually has
been a priority and and jamie foxx who
got an oscar for for ray right uh uh
said uh in in connection with this oscar
uh so white movement he said
act better
be better
raise your game
don't demand don't yell don't scream get
better act better he got an oscar and
and and i think part of the reason he
said that is because
it kind of demeans his oscar
right because then it means
you're complaining that that oscars are
so white how did i get one
i was lucky yeah maybe just maybe i was
excellent
i had never thought about it like that
he got a point because
if
when i say this i'm not saying that it's
completely diminished and it's racism
is not
in
the world period but if it was as bad as
we painted out to be
there would be
we would still be black people will
still be where they are where they were
years ago and there wouldn't be as many
opportunities as there is for
for
black people
at all
and so i
got my eyes opened
and my brain is turning a little bit so
i i can understand that if this is bad
it's as bad as everyone makes it out to
be why
why is all this stuff an option like
it shouldn't be but it is so it's
oh actually i have another question for
you
what do you think about things in
colleges like black student union
i
personally i
like those
because
i think that
for
for me
it was
it was beneficial
and
also
i won't say not beneficial but also like
it for me because of um
just
personally how i fit into the black
community and i've felt this from a
young age where like
when
i would be around
my friends at school and i grew up at in
a predominantly white neighborhood went
to pwis um almost my whole life
it was like they they looked at me
normal they were cool to me treated me
whenever i got
around black people they would look at
me weird even it was me and my brothers
look at me weird
look at us
like just bad give us just weird looks
and it was when i was younger i didn't
like i didn't like being around black
people it was hard because of just the
way i felt around them i didn't feel
like i was welcomed and so growing up
going to a black student union it was
kind of like that
and
i was i felt like i was welcome but
there's things that i like didn't
connect with i was like well am i not
black enough to be able to be here so i
think i think black student unions are
awesome and great but i also think that
it could be a hindrance because there
are certain things in the black
community that a lot of black people
don't
don't do and
it's like if you're not that you get
your black car taken away and it's
it's annoying because why why are we
subject to
certain things that
make us black we're already black
but you have you have to listen to this
type of music you have to um watch these
movies you have to know this type of
food you have to like this and that to
be to be black and it's like no because
you never know someone's situation they
may not have been able to listen to some
type of music they may have never been
able to watch a movie like friday do you
know what friday is
of course she does
and so
it's like you never know what someone's
situation is but just because
they um
they don't have the same upbringing as
you are the same like
just things that are like deemed as
important in the black community they're
not black and so
what would you think of like um in
colleges like black only like dorms or
something like that
i think in certain
colleges it may be not black only
but
having
more
of a maybe like a floor where it's a
majority of
one thing but it's still like mixed
because
at the school that i went to
it was
it's hard because you're
you're around
the same people every day and you don't
have someone
that connects to you connects you just
on just like a
a basic like social level and
for me if i was around
if i was around someone
else like if we if we hung out
all the time
i would need an outlet
to like be around another black person
because there's just things that
there's just things that we do that you
may not understand i'm just like okay i
have to explain it to you and it's not a
bad thing it's just it's just easier
just to be around someone that like
already understands it what do you think
about like a black only like school like
that sort of thing
like a hbcu kind of
sort of yeah
i think they're
beneficial
um
in a lot of ways
i also think there may be
some things that is
a hindrance
um
it's
it's like if you go to if you go to all
my school all
all you know is that and so when you get
out of it
you're not really
connected to the world as a whole
because um
even and i just won't say all wife we go
to all asian all hispanic this and the
third
you
you're not exposed to everybody else so
i
i like
the idea of all that school
i also like the idea of letting others
come in i know that they do that at all
black schools okay i have another
question have you ever thought about how
that's kind of going back to segregation
no
i have not thought about that
sorry
like have you ever thought about how
it's kind of like do you think it's at
all
like
racist to like pick pick people based on
the way they look
i don't
in that sense no and i think the mindset
behind it is
that
everything is geared towards
from what we're like told and what we're
using everything is geared towards one
type of population so we want to be able
to have our thing and not have it
infiltrated
by the others whoever the others is and
we want to be able to
do our thing but how did you say that so
what if there was um a white only dorm
or like majority white will let a couple
black people indoor see
or a white student you do
it's
isn't it weird
how that sounds tasty it's weird because
it when you
not not when you that's okay i'm not
i'm just like wondering like it's weird
isn't it when you say it like that
because of
what
society has been initially like when you
say whites only whites this like that
it says it's like no because that's
that's segregation that's racist that's
that but when you say what about uh
hispanic only or chinese only or black
like what's what's the difference and
because
that has it
been
like
how do i say it that's not the history
yeah when you throw it out there it's
like no that's fine and you put
white in front of it because when you
said that oh no that's segregation that
is unacceptable but i'm like wait what
what's the difference so well it's
interesting too because there were
certain groups of white people were like
do you you've never seen irish need not
apply
yeah there was they they didn't like
irish people for a hot minute in the us
when they first immigrated here
interesting they like had signs that
would say irish people can't apply for
jobs because they're just like a bunch
of drunks
you know huh and that was like a really
big um
i mean i don't this wasn't from a sewell
book guys so i'm butchering it but like
i'm telling you guys where i get my
facts from
they're not just off the top of the dome
yeah but um
i don't know it's just kind of weird how
like we'll say the same thing but if you
reverse it one way like people would be
outraged
but the other way and sometimes i think
i have a theory
that there's like people behind the
scenes that kind of push
these like black only spaces because
they want to go back to segregation
and they like push this on colleges
that's that's a theory i have it might
not be real but like because a lot of
times i'll see things and i'm like
that's kind of like going back to the
way it was because there's been colleges
that have talked about like black lonely
dorms
interesting so do you think
speaking about that do you think that
there should be
a
a bt like a black only
network
a black only network
what do you what's that's what uh bet is
a black entertainment uh television i
think that's what oh i didn't even know
that do i think there should be a black
only network oh that's a good question
um
i
it's harks i really do like that network
personally it is it is kind of fire
[Laughter]
i in certain situations like that
i wouldn't say like no they're like
no there shouldn't like that's not bad
and though inside just like that i would
say
like i would never that would never be
my like something i would
create but honestly i think anyone
can start anything they want to start
and if it works it work i believe in
like just everyone has the choice to
make their own decisions so for sure if
that's something you want to do go for
it i personally i don't really get
offended easy so i don't care yeah so i
just think it's weird that like the
reverse people would get mad you know
what i mean because
if they're
if there ever became a um
w-e-t
oh
even though
the argument that
i've always thrown out when i've hear
people say well you have a a b-e-t and
i'm like you have everything else
everything is geared towards you but if
it uh specifically if it's
wow can't talk if it specifically came
out with the w-e-t
i feel like there would be oh uproar no
no no
i'm just gonna say no white person's
gonna do that like i promise you
like we have our nbc our abc our channel
four very good yeah but
i don't know it's just i don't even say
it in a way like i'm offended because i
don't really it doesn't matter to me
it's just it's weird how it's like the
same thing in reverse yeah and
especially when again like we've talked
about less than one percent of people
today
own slit like none of them
most most people immigrated here
after slavery was done
i wonder
what
i don't know if i'll be if we'll be
alive but
what will this world look like when
everybody that
that essentially came from that
era
of owning slaves is like
dead
and there's like no
like
there's like how do i say it
the people that did own slaves i like
aren't here anymore i wonder if those
values
that they had were taught to their kids
and i wonder if
do you think people that own slaves are
still alive
there's been some people who
were slaves that are still alive really
mm-hmm
um i can't remember off the top of my
head
i don't think like a huge bunch i'm just
curious when did slavery at i was just
from 1865
if they were if they were
oh 1865
it says slavery ended in 1865.
um
uh
look up juneteenth okay you might be
right i was just like
because it was
um
um it says when did slavery officially
end
wait okay
because it
the law went out that slavery was
abolished but then there in texas they
didn't hear about it till
june 19th and i can't remember what year
it was
so
the anniversary date of june 19th 1865.
okay
there's no one alive
just kidding
i think i mean 1865 is you let me know
if i'm wrong in the comments it's been
100 years i misspoke sorry no wait
you're probably thinking of like like
the
um
oh my gosh like the the other
discrimination laws from like this like
there's people alive from like the 60s
and like the
like there's segregation and all that
stuff maybe that's what you're thinking
of
probably because my family is alive and
they were alive during all that yeah um
and i don't i don't know
it's
it's hard
because they're
i wonder if those people that
are descendants of the people who were
slave owners
that got taught those
values that
um that their parents believed in are
they still teaching their kids those
values and then are they are they
teaching their kids those values so do
you think that at times
without that was it just so you want to
know if they're still teaching those
kids those yeah okay
i don't know
yeah cause i saw um a post one day that
um
someone was talking about
the church and how
the values that were passed down
and they were saying like
they may not know it but they're
teaching those values in the church and
that's how their their lens are
like those values that their parents
passed out from
wherever i was like huh
that's interesting so i wonder if
if those images of america are still
like being casted in kids today
so do you think that at times visibility
is important so for example i have i've
had jackie harry on here she was the
first black woman i think she won for
best supporting actress in 227 uh around
i guess it's around 1989 or so at that
time do you think that a certain amount
of visibility may have been more
important than it is now like because
finally a black person did it even if
you don't think that the thing in and of
itself is is important i don't think so
i remember uh some years ago there was
an olympic uh black uh skier named
debbie uh debbie thomas i believe was
her last name and she was the first um
black olympiad in in
in ice skating
and she was constantly asked who are
your role models who are your role
models who inspired you and finally to
me out of out of exasperation she said i
don't need to see somebody black do
something before i think i can do it
and that's how i feel if i want to do
something
what's holding me back from doing it
other than
my own
insecurities or
or or inadequacies just get up make it
happen yeah how exhausted
so does representation even matter
because
and maybe this is from a privileged
point of view but like
this sector of youtube is male dominated
and i just i don't care if there's
there's no guy doing
what i do in this sector of youtube
but i don't i don't care i'm just trying
to it's fun
if you teach kids like you don't have to
see
someone
black doing it you can do it they're
gonna be like okay yeah i can be a
doctor i haven't seen a black doctor
ever in my life i want to be it i like
what they do i'ma do it
except be a priest i used to want to be
a priest as a kid because i i heard
there was never a girl that did it
[Laughter]
i got that mentality like oh there's
never been a woman do it i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna do it
and yeah you can't that one cooked that
dream let it die
look at that that's not change
yeah switch switch church you're not
gonna become a priest
i'd be a good one
i don't mean this literal conversation
right now could you imagine your youtube
channel having being a priest welcome
back to the priests pearly thing i'm
like look
welcome to my sermon guys
the confessional
welcome back to the confessional guy
where i talk about [ __ ] you should
confess for
let's start with sex out of marriage i
know you all be wilding in these streets
i see tick tock
i see tick tock
i'm in what day
what have you all been up to all right
let's
let's then i would go through the
community one by one with the thirst
traps i'd be like
oh
gretchen
what is this
yo your your youtube would be crazy i
don't i i make it i make it a sermon i'd
have i'd have you go viral a lot yeah
yeah and i would i would be like
i'll be like julia that's your daughter
you need to slap some sense in it why is
her ass on the internet
we don't we're a catholic maybe maybe
you should i'd be a great priest maybe
you should maybe create some money
next venture pearl becoming a priest
yeah let me know in the comments if you
if you want me to come to a church near
you i mean you are ordained
to do something i'm a minister though i
am an ordained minister just in case i
ever have an opportunity to marry
someone i just wanted to feel loud there
you go
now but just this thing you know so much
of what you talk about has to
unfortunately be framed around something
that you don't even think is is real you
know what i mean it's something that you
think should be put behind us that
actually is behind us and yet you have
to talk about it a lot just on the
personal note how does that feel for you
doesn't bother me i think there's a lot
of feeling that race and racism remain
major problems in america
and i think that
that you're approaching this with with
with sincerity and and and and real
concern uh i just don't think it's that
big of a deal yeah by the way i've
emailed deray mckesson to have him on
who's the lead i think the quasi leader
of black lives matter he hasn't
responded but i will i will ask him
again so i'm not doing i'm not just
playing favorites here you know i'm just
putting that out no no problem
um
this is america there there are cubans
who are braving shark infested waters to
get here there are people from central
america coming up here why do people
come here why do so many people want to
come to america and it's because it is
the land of the free and the home of the
brave it is a place where you can go
from nothing to something uh faster than
at any time
and anywhere than in all of human
history that's why we're here and um to
me again you are
are almost uh giving the forefinger to
all the people who fought struggled
worked hard and died for people to sit
around in 2017 in [ __ ] mode and wine
about race and racism i am with a
best-selling author a radio host and a
man who once beat me senseless
oh this is a different interview i think
you were right
okay it's like different clips because
it started yeah
in
and then it went to or 2016 and went
2017 and then now is it like all the
years that yeah okay what it would you
think of what he said
it's
it's hard to hear
but if people don't start realizing the
progression and they
their mindset stays where they are
they're always gonna it's always gonna
be there
like like i keep saying i'm not saying
that racism is not a thing and it's like
oh there's no more of that in america
because it's there
but there's things
there's
you don't have to you don't have to that
shouldn't be something that you worry
about like oh
if i step into
this room like what are they going to
think if they think what they think
cool if if they're racist
through and through that's cool go find
another opportunity and
people are focusing on the wrong thing
and so
that is why i think that he said what he
said
i'm just like
i just don't know how you fix it you
know what i mean like you're always
gonna be racist people
so i don't know you can't get rid of
them yeah you can't
fix it
unless you say
you know there is no way like what are
you gonna do kill off all the racist
people you still have people that may
not
necessarily be
racist but they're just not gonna like
you they're not gonna like you and
there's people in the in the own
community that don't like their people
and it's like what are you gonna do kill
them off because they don't like
they don't like us like no like there's
something there's something that
is always gonna be there so it's like
you you can't you can't fix it
it's yeah it's it's inevitable really
millions of people
larry elder welcome back to the reuben
report round two
well this will be round three how are
you this is so we're up to rocky iii
you really caught that before i did i
totally thought this was a different
class
because it was a little the last one was
a little bit darker and i was like did
that change or they
yeah i'm like did his hair grow in like
two seconds he got a wig a piece and i
was like i think that's different
no no it's like muhammad ali and frasier
right ali lost the first one frazier ali
lost the first one won the second one
and then they had the had the big third
one thrown in milo this is thriller in
manila this is thrilling
right see i wish this was more like
rocky because in the original rocky they
it was to a standstill rocky one right
nobody wins rocky two rocky finally wins
and then three well at that point you're
retired i think ruben the only question
is which one of us is ali which one of
us is frasier
[Music]
we shall find out much you'll find out
all right so uh you just sat down here
but we've already talked about comic
books about basketball
black panther yeah uh about racism about
uh trump uh i think speaking of black
panther i cannot unsee
what they said on their podcast now when
they said that i said
and now i'm like oh
tell the camera
so we were on a podcast another night
and we were listening in
and they were saying
they were talking about black panther
and they're saying how it was good for
the american black community of the
afro-like african africans because they
are all from the motherland from africa
they're saying that it was just like it
was an average movie and it was lion
king
basically just in people form and at
first i was like how can how dare you
say that when they were talking about
how um
he like fell from the mountaintop and
everything and i was like
yo
i was like if you think about it
lion king's a great movie so why not
it's a it's a fire movie why not do it
in people's form
so i was like yo
pride rock it was there you can't see it
just like the red pill
all right well let's do a little bit of
it for the people so i first i just want
to jump back to that original moment
because i said it to you last time you
were here which was about a year ago
and when that that moment where you
really beat me senseless about systemic
racism that was about two years ago
already if not more at this point and so
many people i was just in london two
days ago and i did a q a and people were
asking me about it i mean that thing
really
has there are many versions of it on
youtube it's just caught fire and as i
said to you last time it was sort of i
view it as my best moment and my worst
it was my worst because i came to a an
intellectual fight without the proper
equipment and it was my best because we
left it in and let it be and it was a
learning moment for me and then for
everyone else well you had a lot of
class for leaving it in a lot of people
would have would have taken it out and
no one would have known it happened and
secondly the older one gets the more
difficult it is for one to kind of
change one's beliefs and for you to do
it at your age to rethink your
assumptions uh uh takes a lot of a lot
of guts a lot of people don't want to do
that
and i think it's a pretty depressing
thing don't you think i i agree with you
most people don't want to do it i think
we've fostered here something that is
allowing people to do it but most people
don't want to do that you know and it's
funny we're in an atmosphere where just
a moment ago i'm driving in listening to
um
talk radio and i think it's cnn or msnbc
and they're going on and on about how
trump has now made lying uh the currency
of the day and and no one tells the
truth anymore facts don't matter and
they're talking about the kinds of lying
that trump does where he talks about the
crowd size and how much money he has and
stuff like that the lies of the left are
huge lies and they damage the country
the lie that racism remains a major
problem in america it's a lie the lie
that women make 77 cents on the dollar
for doing the same thing that men do it
it's a lie the lie that rich get rich
the poor get poorer these are lies and
these are big lies that drive the left
and drive votes these are the kinds of
things that matter so when you sit
across from a guy you ever notice that
all of those things that they're lying
about in in
make you scared
incite fear
and anxiety and like stress
that's one thing that
i noticed with this last election
a lot of it was fear-based and i'm like
if people actually researched and just
bumped the media bumps social
news outlets and really like look for
themselves
i think it would have went a little bit
differently but
it was a lot of fear basically if you
like this one this is what the world is
going to be like if you like this one
this is what the world's going to be
like instead of just going off of facts
yeah
and it's
it's interesting too because
i don't know the media just paints
the the right is so bad
like i don't know i don't know why
the media like hates the right but i
just feel like they have money in places
that they don't want the conservatives
to like touch
you know what i mean
like i don't know like they don't want
their money taken out of like schools or
out of like special interest groups and
that sort of stuff like i think there
just has to be some connection between
the media and the left because it is so
left-leaning like even entertainment
yeah like you were saying um the other
day how that one show
was very like politically pushed yeah
like once you see it you can't see it
you'll see all these political like
like yeah it it i think it's to
brainwash the next generation of voters
from a young age
they're trying to get what i said if you
get them at a young age you got them
they're trying to get trans like they're
trying to teach trans stuff in schools
that's that's politic like politicizing
kids
yeah once you see it you cannot see it
the first time we did it when i really
still felt i was part of the left i was
trying to reform the left realistically
i'm not part of the left anymore you
know and again the left right thing as
we talk about all the time doesn't even
have that much meaning anymore it's
really about authoritarians libertarians
and all that um
but for all the years that you've been
doing this staking out conservative
positions for how many years publicly 25
25 years
was there a more sensible left at the
time was there a guy you could sit
across from that you disagreed with
intellectually but felt that it was it
was forthright it was honest you just
disagreed with the methodology and and
the results sure there were lots of
people that i felt that way with and
william buckley had a very good friend
uh uh john kenneth galbraith who was a
left-wing economist they disagreed about
everything they were good friends uh
believe it or not antoine scalia's best
friend on the supreme court is ruth
bader ginsburg what it requires is
somebody to recognize that if i have a
position that's different from yours it
doesn't mean that i'm a bad guy it
doesn't mean that i'm evil it means that
i see the world differently it takes a
certain kind of maturity to do that say
it louder for the people in the back sir
oh that that right there
it
i feel like if more people understood
that
a lot of things would not be a problem
if people just understood
that
you're not going to think like me and
i'm not going to think like you but i'm
open to hear what you have to say to see
to try to understand how you see the
world i may not agree with you in the
end
but
i'm open to it and so many people are
not
open to having conversations like that
to where they disagree it's like how how
can you see the world like that this is
actually what's happening he's like
but you cannot
everybody sees the world differently
everybody and to dismiss someone's
literally eye gates that they experience
the world through it's just the missing
dismissing them in general and i feel
like if more people were more open to
that and understood
that
there i think that's why the audience
likes you is you're very open
it's rare no it's rare now yes yes it is
very rare nowadays because there's some
things that
we have talked about i'm like
yeah okay like i hear you and i'm like
okay like i understand how she can see
it like that i still think the way that
i think but it's like i'm not like oh my
gosh pearl how could you ever think that
you know i've had people stop being
friends with me over this channel i had
my best friend of like
20 years
stop telling me she couldn't be my
friend anymore
wow because of the stuff i post and i'm
like okay so you're telling me this is
crazy about the left i bet you if i
started an only fans she'd be cool with
that content i bet she would still be my
friend still support me
but i post conservative values
and i'm the bad guy yeah
it doesn't make sense it's making me
it's this girl oh my gosh um
so it was just funny because
like because her whole argument was like
well my kids that she doesn't even have
kids she's like my future kids are going
to see this and i'm just like
so you want to stop being friends with
me now for kids that you don't have norm
do you want to cross that bridge when we
get there yeah exactly so essentially
she didn't really want to be your friend
period because if it's something like
that that stops you from being your
friend oh
i'm a big ball of fun too she's missing
out she is missing out she could have
flew out to london and been on your show
sorry ma'am you're missing out
a big ball of fun
we have good times over here
unfortunately we've gotten to the place
now where if you don't believe that
racism is a major problem in america uh
if you're black you're a sellout if
you're white you're a racist if you say
something negative about the black
panther which i just did
i got hammered some some guy told me
that well it's because it's a black
person and a black director and a black
hero and therefore you don't like it
i mean the star is guy named chadwick
boseman and i was fortunate enough to be
invited to see the premiere of 42. he
was brilliant i saw the movie three or
four times i like him so much i saw him
in a movie about uh thurgood marshall
which was a very good movie probably not
commercially uh uh uh successful but it
was a very good movie
and i saw him play in the movie with uh
we played james brown he was very good
the movie wasn't that good but he was
good yeah so he's an intriguing actor
again i don't go to see a movie to to
not be happy to waste my time yeah and
you're a comic book guy i mean the
reason we were talking about comic books
is because i've got a whole bunch in the
green room here
what he just said about um
the movies and the movies that chadwick
boseman did
a lot of them a few of them that he said
they just didn't do good in the um
in the box office or in
wherever they were showing and
that's something that goes into play
what we're talking about in the oscars
like there's a lot of
great black actors that
do these
movies that just
don't turn out great and they just
don't perform well at the other as these
other ones and so
i wonder if they're having those
conversational how how do we do
how do we get to a point where we're
able to
produce these great films produce
all of this great work
and then
get
produce it to where it's at a standard
where it can hang with the big dogs and
then
it's essentially
how am i trying to say this
so
rewind i wonder if they're having those
conversations so okay where can what do
we need to do to be able to be in the
mix with all these other
great movies that are white led to be
able to be in the mix with them and be
at the standard that they are i don't
know if they're having those
conversations because a lot of a lot of
black movies
you you really
nowadays you see them but some of them
are very under the radar undercover and
if we don't if they're not pushed by
mainstream we don't know about them and
i wonder if that's the type of
conversation they're having to be able
to be recognized at the officers or
they're just like the oscars are too
white
yeah which one do you think could be
more effective
if of the two the two conversations yeah
i would think the not the oscars are too
white but the how do
what what is it that they're doing
what is the formula not the formula but
like how
let's let's look at it a little bit or
let's just produce
better movies or produce great films to
where if we do not get recognized then
we can say oh why don't we get
recognized here when looking across the
board we are exactly the same with the
winning cop with the winning competition
why don't we get recognized as well you
know what's interesting so i think about
the jordan peterson interview
where jordan peterson was arguing with
that feminist right and the feminist was
the one complaining about the problem
and jordan peterson was the one actually
fixing it because he was helping women
get better wages right and it's almost
like
are you happy about that and it's almost
like the people that are the loudest do
nothing that's what you're gonna you're
gonna once you see this you can't unsee
it like
i swear to god the the friends i have
that were the loudest about like black
lives matter when like everything was
going on they don't
even interact with black people ever
and like they they don't do anything in
their day to day like but they'll post
on social media and complain but i i
know them you're not donating to any
cause
you're not you're not doing anything
and they're the same ones that'll text
me and be like why didn't you post
anything daddy you're conservative
and and but i'm like
[ __ ] you need to like one one
you don't even have five dollars to your
name i know you're not doing [ __ ] for
this
like maybe get off your phone
go get an extra job save a little money
and then donate it donate something but
it's like a lot of times when you ask
people or you'll be like why don't you
give up your position
or like like when they're
they actually have to do something it's
like nothing yep
that's and once you see this you can't
you can't see it
you were immediately going on about all
this stuff you loved so it's not like
you're walking into that thing to hate
it right and so the criticism is just
bizarre i mean
what do you think i am what do you think
i do i get up in the morning hate myself
gouge my eyeballs out try to claw my
skin color off and that's just
and and and dave i feel sorry for people
like that people have often asked me
does it make you mad it doesn't i feel
sorry for you if you are so trained so
indoctrinated to be that's rabid against
somebody who just has a different point
of view there's a problem with you not
with me
you did it
you decided to get in the game
i had people they're really up in this
production club yeah i see the i see the
come up dave
i see the come up
there's a gajillion people out there
like fix california nobody ever no good
people decent people ever want to get in
what finally dragged you to do it so
many people like you
wait larry elder's running for office
where i didn't even know he said why
don't you do this dennis prager first
asked me and i said
dennis hell no he said why i said
california is practically ungovernable
we have two-thirds super majority in the
senate two-thirds super majority in the
assembly plus a left-wing governor the
environmentalists run this state the
teachers union dominate the state it's
almost ungovernable hell is he trying to
be
like recently because this sounds recent
because this is this clip is from 2021
is it oh he isn't running for governor
but he may run for president
oh huh
okay you
would you vote for him
when did he say he was shot i mean 2022
is 2022 the next election
[Music]
for president oh sorry sorry no has it
been four years already i met like
that's when the article came out no
larry elder isn't running for california
government but he may run for president
um
larry
elder won more votes than any other
candidate hoping to take gavin newsom's
job in california's recall election in
2021
okay so i guess he did run but he will
not be running for california governor
in 2022 i'm a realist i know that in
california democrats and independents
who typically vote democrats outnumber
republicans almost three to one so i'm
not sure a rematch in short term would
make a whole lot of sense
um yeah but
basically he's thinking about running
for the next president would you vote
for him
personally i would
i would want to see what else he stood
for you think about it yeah i would
think about it but i know that
a lot of people wouldn't yeah
based off of how
he thinks and
that sucks because
some of the ways that i've heard some of
the things that i've heard him said
would be so beneficial
for the black community
but if they're not open to
a progression in that way
he would be called anything and
everything
in the book of names
by the community
because they because
it's different
that's interesting if i see you on the
if i see you on the ballot sir
they ponder on it
oh no then it's good okay i understand
and then i got approached by a guy named
pastor jack hibbs also a very good
friend of mine
and he made the same argument dennis did
and then a friend of mine named lionel
chapman chetwin a longtime filmmaker
also made the same argument and then
just normal people that i know in my
life my gardener my the guy that drives
me from time to time the guy that opens
the door when i come into my uh to my
office buildings from time to time
people that were that i work with and
nobody said well larry geez you have a
great life and my goodness you're
starting to make money now and
and you've got a long time relationship
with your girlfriend nina why jeopardize
all that and nobody's lived a perfect
life and i'm sure you haven't too why
expose and no one said that i kept
waiting for somebody i respect to say
that
my mother and my father are no longer
with us uh my brother just died he was
my best friend he died september 13 2019
two weeks before his 70th birthday and i
know what he would have said he would
have said go for it that's just how he
is
my mom would have said go for it my dad
would have been more reluctant about my
own privacy and my own career but my
mother would have said go for it she's
been more political than i am so i
couldn't i ran out of reasons not to do
it and the more i watched gavin newsom
the more he ticked me off the way he was
sitting at that restaurant called the
french laundry
dave i never heard that restaurant until
he was there i thought it was probably
the most elite restaurant in california
it's not i thought it was the most elite
restaurant in america is not it's one of
the most elite restaurants in the world
oh yeah an area is sitting there
incurring a tab some people say it's 12
grand i heard it as high as 30 grand
with the very medical professionals uh
and the lobbyists that drafted the
mandates that they were violating by not
wearing masks and by not socially
distancing at the height of lockdown
this wasn't two weeks and his two kids
were enjoying in-person private
education and he accepted his own winery
from the from the mandates
when those pictures came out in
california
oh people were pissed because he we were
all forced to wear masks everywhere and
restaurants like certain restaurants
couldn't have a certain capacity because
of the mass
and people were pissed they said gavin
newsom is at a restaurant no mass people
around him no mess he's just chilling
there it's like how can he do that they
were trying to get him out of there yeah
well it's crazy because this is another
thing you can't unsee is they they make
laws for other people that they don't
even follow
that's why like people should not
have get to make laws like that they
don't follow themselves how messed up is
that yeah you should have some
repercussions the law is for you too if
you don't want to follow it don't make
the law so the question is why
are they pushing these laws if they
don't believe it themselves
it's about control they want to know
that they can control people um next log
avenue some makes i ain't following it
unless it's something that's very bad
and i should follow it
and this kind of arrogant smug entitled
attitude really started taking me off
and then you add to that the crime and
the homelessness and the hellacious cost
of living in california
see with that i would want to hear
his stand on all that stuff
um
if he was
running for governor even if he was
running for president i would want to
hear his stand on that
larry you're scared blown me away once
or twice over the years but are you
telling me that the conservatives are
not racist are you are you telling me
that the conservatives don't hate gay
people and that the conservatives
generally want to live and let live is
that is that what you're dropping that's
right that's what i'm saying most people
want people to realize their potential
why would it be in anybody's best
interest for a group of people to be
to perceive
them as racist how is that making things
better don't you want everybody to be
law abiding
drug abstaining tax paying people
doesn't that make everything good
and whenever i ask people about systemic
racism i always say can you can you name
names what do you get david duke after
that after that the list is pretty short
isn't it yeah give me the name who in
congress on the republican side is
systemically racist give me the name
give me the name and sometimes they say
trump are you kidding me
best economy ever under trump he
pardoned jack johnson the first black
heavyweight champion that obama didn't
do despite the fact that ken burns the
lefty uh documentarian came to obama and
said please pardon this guy didn't do it
sylvester stallone please pardon the guy
didn't do it trump does it he also uh
commuted the sense of a woman named
alice johnson who has done a very very
long trump hotel very long non-violent
drug offense uh he put permanent funding
of historically black colleges on for
10-year footing no one had done that
before expanded opportunity zones
dropping some of the rules and
regulations in distressed areas so that
you you invite more business if he is a
racist he needs to go back to racism
school when you were watching the state
of the union and he mentioned lois black
unemployment of all time and then to
watch the congressional black caucus
right like to me that was everything
that you've preached about in your 40
years doing this how many years you've
been on here
with
with
it's hard
because
i'm going to say it's hard a lot because
it's hard people but don't come in the
comments
these aren't easy topics yeah no and
it's
it's okay to not be sure how yeah you
know but i've i heard
i heard um that he i can't remember
exactly what he did in
the
black community in the south but trump
did but i know that he
did something positively
and what just the things he was naming
off
i heard some of those
but it's
in the back of my mind i'm like what was
he doing it for was he doing it for his
own gain but it shouldn't be like that
it should be like if you see
he
he essentially did
things
for
more things for the black community
than
any other president before him
and
it's
it sucks that
stuff like that
isn't
shown
to like show like hey there is yes
he may say off the wall stuff yes he may
have done this that and the third with
whomever
and is not right
but
let that stuff be like legal stuff that
he has to do with on his own that's not
affecting
that's not affecting america that's that
let's focus on like the actual things
that he's doing
and
whatever he says out of his butt he can
say it but it's his
is the tactics not tactics but is the
things he's doing positively affecting
whatever community is in or is it
negatively affecting
whatever it's set for do you think
intentions matter
what do you mean by that so like when i
look at someone
i don't really care what a president's
intentions are i care about what he did
and how it affected people and what the
results were
and i think a lot of times we'll focus
on like people's hidden intentions but
at the end of the day you're never going
to know why someone did something
you will literally never know and if
trump was so racist why was he so
accepted in pulp pop culture by like
like he was on tv for so long and nobody
had an issue with him yeah he was on
like he was in that what's that movie
the the home alone movie everyone loved
him he was on like i'm pretty sure some
rappers have had him in music videos
a few things yeah but like why was he
only racist the second he ran into
office that's something that i noticed
as well and tried to change things
i like that's why i think there's people
behind the scenes that just like that in
the media yeah because that's weird if
he was racist it would the media loves
canceling people
so why didn't it come out before
i don't know i've had that thought like
i don't
when he wasn't in
office or trying to run for president
i never saw anything about him being
racist but as soon as he came in
for
what
what i may think when he came into
office
from what i saw it was like all the
undercover people that were
racist
or
were against
whomever
it like brought them to light and it
gave them gave them a voice in a sense
and that's something that i notice and
i don't know if that's why people
connect that to him or they just have
the thought that he's racist i'm not
sure but i just wish that
more of the things that he did
were talked about because it
it was stuff that you never know like
when he was talking about um
the unemployment went down i was like
when did that happen when i first heard
that i was like huh that was you
remember the economy was booming before
the
uh before covet happened
yeah it was like record high wow
it was the economy was doing real well
before that happened
and then it's kind of like
coveted kind of seems a little like
isn't that a little weird i've i've
always thought coped was weird i was
like hmm it kind of turns out all of a
sudden
right yeah right right before the next
election
and then the vaccine came out right
after the election mm-hmm
trust me and then black lives like the
black lives matter came in like that
that whole movement right before it's
just weird timing
trust me we go on and on all day about
the covet i've had my thoughts about it
and
yeah
at this point 27 27 i gave you an extra
14. but
[Music]
it must have just been like man i have
been screaming about this stuff here's
the guy doing this stuff and they dare
sit there but it's just one little
example they've been doing this for
years uh obama's mom sent him back from
indonesia when he's 10 years old to
eventually go to punahou the finest prep
school in the state of hawaii because
she wanted him to have better education
michelle obama did not go to a charter
school they didn't exist then but she
did not go to her local government
school because it was so bad she got on
the bus and went to a much better school
ice cube the rapper uh he didn't go to
his local government school he went to
taft with the time with predominantly
white so what are they telling you
they're telling you they want choice but
you don't get choice and they're
beholden to the teachers union that
adamantly opposes choice for all the
reasons i just now mentioned they don't
get their automatic dues from the
teachers union and therefore it
threatens them they couldn't care less
about the quality of education
and i mentioned the 300 000 teachers
in
in
in
public school teachers in california and
the average year only 2.2 were fired
imagine
i told you between five and seven
percent of them are perceived to be
incompetent there are twenty thousand
cops here in in uh in la
imagine if five percent of them were bad
cops that's a thousand cops on the
streets we wouldn't put up with it we
put up with 15 000 bad teachers who
wants to do something about that we do
they don't but i'm the bad guy i'm the
uncle tom think about it open up your
eyes who's on your side now the beauty
of our of our private ballots is you can
go in there
and you're a mailing ballot and you can
vote for a republican and nobody has to
know about it so i'm telling these
independents and democrats pull the
lever for me don't tell anybody
i'm touching it who's on your side i'm
going to tell people if you're looking
for more honesty
yo yo
what
that actually wasn't
the interview i thought it was but what
did you think
you know what pearl
i'm gonna i'm gonna need a new brain
after this this whole thing
it
it's good to see a black person talk
like this honestly because
it's a different view
and
it
opens up
your view as a black person
to
to know that
maybe there aren't this many obstacles
in the way and maybe
maybe the stuff that my parents dealt
with or my grandparents dealt with
is
not as big
as it was to where
it's
a force that i
i can't i can't progress like it's just
that wall that i can't progress past
maybe now now it's not a wall maybe it's
a little gate that i can crop climb over
and then progress
so i
i liked it i don't know if that's the
fact that i liked it but
you know call me what you want i think
the way i want what do you know they'll
love you on my channel that when the
other side finds that they might not but
that's
hopefully if the other side sees it
they'll be open hopefully their
minds will be open and
they'll have conversation well i think
it's good because people have these
conversations behind the scenes they're
just afraid to get on camera yes
yes are afraid to talk to
family and friends that think
differently and don't want to start an
argument
okay guys um you want to do the outro
yeah so i hope you hope you lots enjoyed
the video and um
yes like comment subscribe
and make sure you follow our instagrams
mine is its.ya.underscoregirljess
and follow me on youtube as well
it's the same thing it's the girl jess
and be on the lookout for some videos on
that have a great day
[Music]